The joe rogan experience.
I mean,
I guess the one film,
I recommend that everyone is killer season,
right?
Camrons Killa season.
What does that do?
Well,
Santana's in all the dips at dudes are in it.
It's like the worst made Phil Testes.
Oh,
you don't listen to the Dipset.
Oh she's anyway,
I alone ongoing shit with the dip set is yo,
y'all don't know the dip set.
Y'All don't know the dips in my grandfather's rolling over these fucking kids
today.
Don't know the dips.
You just ask my grandson.
Y'All don't know that.
I just put your fucking pants up.
I just put you on this some Shit Joe.
Cause you need to get diplomatic immunity.
One diplomatic immunity to watch Killa season.
What?
What am I killing?
See we talked to Minuchin women shitting cocaine out of their asses.
It's awesome.
Did you guys,
I was going to bring this up yesterday.
Did you guys hear about this guy who got arrested with a hundred bags of heroin
up his ass?
Not hundred bags.
Hundred bags.
It was a traffic stop.
It's his ass.
Hold him is virtual.
You have a sink hole in your pants,
sir.
It's a hundred bags of heroin,
man.
100 the man.
Oh,
oh Jesus.
Okay.
I look,
I look this Killa season.
No,
no,
this one's okay.
This guy just had one.
Okay.
This is the other guy had it his ass.
So this dude gets busted on the Palisades parkway.
They pull him over and his 2005 Mitsubishi Lancer and he's acting real weird.
And um,
so they decided to bring him in.
So they bring him in and they open up his ass.
They just gave him a cavity check.
I mean the guy didn't do anything wrong and they pulled him over.
He just looked weird.
He was tweaking out on his own.
Something was going on with him,
man.
He was pulled over.
I mean routine traffic stop.
But they,
they detected the smell of marijuana and that's where they,
uh,
that's where they got them and they brought him in because they smelled
marijuana.
That's it.
And he had a hundred bags of heroin up his ass.
And you can't put a hundred bags of heroin up your ass while the cops are going
from their car to your car.
You can't do that.
So driving around with those packed up,
is that,
why would you drive around and smoke weed with a hundred packs of heroin in your
ass?
Well,
I think he's just one of those guys.
That's his move.
Maybe it's like,
like Russian checks.
We'll put Ben Wa balls and their pussy to tighten up their must there.
Fuck muscle.
Maybe this dude was just like exercise and his his ass door starfish,
starfish.
I maybe he didn't trust his roommate's like,
man,
if I leave,
this is a hundred bags of heroin later.
These motherfuckers get itself.
He went to the gym,
he's like,
man,
I can't fit it in my pocket.
I can't leave.
I can't leave it in my dash.
Let's work on that star fish.
The glove box is full.
I just stuffed this up my ass.
Hmm.
Can I fit a hundred beds?
Let's five six.
Wow.
Am I really going to get 94 more?
And he ever put anything up your ass like,
like a pill or anything ever like a net wash cloth washcloth.
Yeah.
Finger finger on the end of a washcloth.
I've never gotten that.
Yeah,
it was clean it out.
Picture you go inside the room.
Asked manicure soap.
The little soap.
Little Polish.
Never.
Yeah.
I've never done that.
No.
Have you?
Uh,
no.
I was just,
I've never even take a thermometer but some mometer yeah,
I had a doctors stick a finger up my ass once.
I had to like when you're a kid,
when you have a fever,
they fucking put like Advil in your ass.
I think.
Yeah.
It's,
I've never been into the girl putting her finger in my ass.
No,
no.
Never had that happen.
But they say it's amazing.
It's so I,
I just,
I don't want to go there.
I'm not going to open that book to be amazing though.
It could be amazing as opposed to be like a prostate massage thing and Eugene
shoot like a fucking broken fire.
Hydrilla Joe,
I think you pretty much saying.
Yeah.
So the third sponsor of the podcast,
his fingers
go to afford backslash Joe Rogan finger up the S.
Dot com
it tapers pinky.
I use the code name.
Don't ask for the third finger.
You can save yourself
10% off.
Embarrassment.
Yeah,
because a girl like if she's like,
you want me to put a second hand finger?
And you're like,
yeah.
Yeah.
What about third?
Okay.
No,
no third though.
You're fucked up.
What's wrong with you?
He wants three.
He wanted me three fingers up his ass.
Oh,
you need to get out.
You need a better man in your life.
You'll get of his break.
You've never had a girl try.
I've had to go try.
A lot of them will always try and like jokingly so never let it happen.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Never,
never.
Some site that tickles and makes me feel gross.
I'm one of the people that believe or subscribe into the thing that,
uh,
that there's no,
you're not allowed.
Have to look at it.
You're not allowed to see it.
You're not,
let's smell it.
You're not allowed to touch it.
I don't want anything out of my ass.
I don't know why.
Hey man,
whatever.
It's good.
It's probably a mess.
I mean,
I don't see you like Groman.
Yeah.
I don't see you like getting down there with a fucking mirror and,
uh,
in a big three blade,
it's time for that Joe Polish in that area up.
Nice.
Cleaning it up.
A company.